les villes d'udon basse sous alerte
aérienne en quasi-permanence
rues désertées dans la ville de ce lot
viance que et déflagrations d'artillerie
[Musique]
les civils qui n'ont pas fui ne sortent
que pour les distributions alimentaires
files d'attentes et pensions sur tous
les visages
on a peur et très peur
peur de connaître exactement le même
sort que les habitants de severodonezk
plus à l'est une ville pilonnée par les
russes ou les soldats ukrainiens ont en
ce moment les plus grandes difficultés
nous allons justement sur une position
ukrainienne de ce front est
tranché fraîchement creusées et tirs de
roquettes vers les positions russes
ces soldats ont reçu l'ordre de battre
en retraite à robin et villes prises
récemment par les russes témoignage rare
leur moral n'est pas bon c'est un drame
d'avoir du recul et
on ne voudrait jamais avoir à faire ça
ce que l'on veut nous s'est attaqué
à robijns et c'était impossible de se
défendre on était obligé de se retirer
l'artillerie russe détruisent et où tout
était rasé il n'y avait plus aucune
position possible pour se cacher
remonter le moral des troupes c'est
exactement le sens de cette visite du
président céline ski sur ce front très
exposé et de l'est
remise de médailles et mots de soutien
au soldat
prenez soin de vous c'est très important
parce que sans vous notre pays n'est
rien 8 g ros du fond de mon coeur je
vous souhaite le meilleur
il cela fonctionne ces deux soldats sont
en position sur un terrain d'aviation
désaffecté ils nous disent être très
touché par ce déplacement du président à
chaque village chaque kilomètre perdu
est un coup dur pour ces soldats d'où
cette intervention du président zelensky
pour consolider l'esprit de résistance
de ses hommes